a rendez vous pour mieux connaître ses
droits c'est le défi de cette journée
départementale du handicap mise en place
par le conseil départemental des stands
d'information pour permettre aux
personnes porteuses d'un handicap de
trouver des solutions immédiates à leurs
problèmes retirer le dossier
la cour a pris ce dossier et on en a
besoin parce que j'avais pas renseigné
il y en a beaucoup qui profitent des
indicateurs les gens surtout à la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
mdph très sollicité en cette journée sur
le stand des formulaires pour permettre
aux visiteurs de remplir tout de suite
leur dossier et un ordinateur pour
étudier les éléments qui les concernent
ça tombe bien parce que je devais me
déplacer à l'ailé mais là comme pour moi
c'est mieux c'est vrai que ce type de
tourner à l'avantagé qu'on a les
informations à côté donc si quelqu'un
vient pas ce qu'il veut comme madame une
info sur le pass transport
nous on ne s'occupe pas du pat rafter
mais il ya le stand juste à côté qui
peut donner les informations d'autres
lieux que quand une personne se déplace
à la mdph sur la réorienter elle doit
refaire des démarches l'est se déplace
de quelques pas et à la les informations
plus près c'est un pass loisirs pass
transport gip-sap et casgrain r&d
dispositif qui s'adresse aux personnes
en situation de handicap
parmi les stands les cars jaunes et la
nouveauté pour voyager en toute liberté
la carte réuni passe la grande nouveauté
aujourd'hui c'est de proposer sa carte
de transport réunis grâce aux personnes
âgées de plus de 65 ans et aux ports et
aux personnes handicapées porteuses d'un
handicap avec un taux supérieur à 50% de
voyager à travers ce titre phare et non
pas de manière gratuite
une nouvelle carte disponible d'ici
l'année prochaine une journée placée
sous le signe de la découverte les
visiteurs ont pu se familiariser avec le
travail du bois de goyavier instant pris
d'assaut et qui a connu un grand succès
jean claude et jean philippe ont chacun
fabriquer un objet en bois tombés bio en
telle matière bois débris a bien plu
c'est joli ça viendra mettre et bijoux
au niveau du toucher oui moi je suis en
voyant déjà listé ça avec ce casque et
vert c'est intéressant parce qu'on sent
bien le côté lisse
je vois deux cd
c'est après quand ce sera terminé on va
on va venir
nassimah dindar présidente de la
collectivité a inauguré cette journée en
présence de deux parrains d'exception du
cowboy et amélie c'est dans le baron
pour lui tous les deux médaillés aux
derniers jeux des îles
j'arrive à des compétitions et j'étudie
3 francs championnat de france handikart
petite naleigh marina
dans la passion et j'ai beaucoup aimé
après je consomme d'une large partie le
avec le 5 mai au cac après lâche pas ce
soit via les familles qui ne vous
connaissent pas encore les toits pour le
peu que j'ai vu le film en date
d'aujourd'hui à des familles ne le sont
pas tout à fait français
on jouera une journée comme on veut
aujourd'hui c'est justement le moment de
passer des informations de l'initiation
et puis du spectacle avec la chorale de
l'amicale du conseil départemental
une journée qui s'était envolé avec
zorro chang
rendez vous est pris pour l'année
prochaine